um
talk about what your album like i know
you you kind of switched up a little bit
of
the sound on some records especially
like with the melodic [ __ ] i mean
going in in that direction on some of
the songs like
and you've always kind of done that to
an extent but like what is
do you feel like this is like your
i feel like i've heard the growth on
this project
the most that's where that's where i was
at with it in my mind too i
so 2019 like we talked about i put out
one
project and with that one project
we were on tour as well when i got off
tour i was like you know what
i'm i'm not even going hurry up and rush
to be like yo i don't need to put the
album album album
i just got my pen right you know i mean
so i got a bunch of the song like maybe
100 200 songs from 2019
that i never even released just because
it was like me it was like
studying practicing and stuff like that
so i like put that on myself and said
i'm not even going to worry about the
album just going right right right right
right right right
and that's why you hear the melodic
sounds the more
uh there's more message in it you know
what i mean like a mixtape i can get in
there and blah blah blah
but this is like personal [ __ ] that i
haven't said in all this time like i
haven't
said stuff about like my uncles and like
things like that passing away
and like not being at home when my
grandma passed away and not
being at the funeral and things like
that being in the hood [ __ ] turning
their back on you [ __ ] kicking in my
door
and come to find out it was some [ __ ]
i knew and like you know i mean stuff
like that so i never really talked about
like my
one thing i really didn't talk about is
like my car getting shot up 12 times
with me
in the car and not getting hit you know
what i'm saying like back home
yeah this was back home right in front
of my mom's house when did that happen
what year like
maybe i want to say
16 like 2016. that just happened 19
yeah so it was trippy
it was it was like not trippy but it was
it was trippy like tripp
i was about to say trippy red was like
12 at this it was tripping me out
because it's like it's on the block
it's on the block where i did everything
you feel me like
in front of my mom's house so when the
[ __ ] started happening i ain't even
really like
it really were you inside of your car
yeah bro i was sitting there like
rolling weed like
smoking like rolling weed about to smoke
and i had talking to some girl on the
phone
and i like hey when i pulled up i never
put my because what i do is when i pull
up if i'm listening to music
i let the song just play right and then
i turn the car off and get out and go
no matter what i'm listening right but i
was just rolling the weed and like
talking to some girl and
all i heard was wow and i ain't paying
no attention because it's
my block i'm like [ __ ] shoot in
the air and do [ __ ] all the time right
it was 9 45 in the morning though
wow i'm like whoa whoa wow
i'm like oh [ __ ] they shooting at the
car
mind you i'm still looking straight not
knowing where it come from
and then the fourth shot i looked over
and i hit the car too
like wow i'm like oh [ __ ] then all the
rest of them start coming to the
windshield
i slid down hit the door now my foot's
on the break i never put the car in park
i slid down hit the door latch let my
foot go off the brake and the car went
that way like towards where
the [ __ ] were shooting from and
then i just dug behind it
and let it roll and then like skirt
around the corner and [ __ ] and it was
like
and at that time i never like as i'm
running like there's a little corner
store it ain't funny but it's funny
there's a little corner store
my adrenaline was going so crazy that i
even know if i was hit or not
but i could feel the [ __ ]
whizzing past and hitting the
head rest i could feel all of that [ __ ]
like you did you were like [ __ ]
yeah so i just so you sit down like you
opened the door and just kind of rolled
out of the car and bounced yeah like i
put my hand down and like
kind of like creeped up the side of the
car and then like two more shots went
off like bow bow and i'm like all right
cool i'm get around the corner were you
like
do you know who it was you know the
streets you know
well like at the because i feel like i
mean at that time did you have any sort
of issues with
with some nah that's not even like my i
feel like that's not your energy yeah
that's not my energy at all but you know
i you know where i'm from and you know
family and you know stuff like that i'm
in you know i'm saying i'm tied in
regardless of anything you know i'm
saying and you're part of it you're
probably like the face of the
fam because you're the biggest [ __ ]
yeah that too but you know it's like
it's just it's you know neighborhood
[ __ ] man
neighborhood [ __ ] sometimes you don't
have nothing to do with [ __ ] and that
could have been like a
you know a bad case right there for for
nothing type of deal
you know what i mean damn i didn't know
that man so yeah because i never said it
i never i never
you know what i'm saying like you see
dolphy like put me a mixtape called 100
shots like
at the same time i was like yo by the
way shout out to young dolph
not only for being the good homie but
jesus man they really try to get that
food he pulled through
twice like these [ __ ] was
really trying to kill the young dog for
like a year straight
yeah that was crazy and that's all i
could think of at that time i was just
like [ __ ]
and like now with the nipsy stuff and
all that [ __ ]
i mean what was the young man from
pittsburgh who died the same day wapo
yeah yeah yeah yeah man that's crazy
because you could have been bro
like i think that that is the one thing
like when x when x got murdered
it was like yo man like you cannot move
around
where you're from like it's all good if
you're his if you're that big
like it's it sucks to say it but it
feels like
where you're like instead of people
being the most proud of you where you're
from
it's like you get the most hate if you
may if you're and it's crazy because
you're the most that's where you're the
most comfortable as well yeah you feel
like you
you know it's just i feel like people
really
you're you're like them and they're mad
that like well what's so special about
that guy
like he's from where i'm from like and
i'm [ __ ] still you know
i don't know right seven kids in the
trap
[ __ ] it don't really be people in
your it only
it's not people in your circle or people
that you know or like
people sometimes in few cases it's
people you grow up
right but it's just some random yeah
it's like from the from the city it's
like it'll be a lot of talk
i'm not even [ __ ] famous like that
but i'm from phoenix and there's people
who want it like
like i don't even know these people and
i'm like wait you why do you hate me
yeah they don't like you because your
position i'm so confused
yeah yeah it's ridiculous damn well i'm
glad that you man
that's crazy that's crazy